foreign
hey you guys it's Monday again holy crap
it looks it feels like we just did one
of these like [ __ ] weeks are flying
by yeah time goes by once you get old
man yes it seems like a day's not even
worth it
it's not that's wake up that's the
spirit yeah you wake up you go no
there's not enough time so you should go
back to sleep because this shit's gonna
take a week you know
well think about that well the weird
thing about that is that like time seems
to go really fast but also
simultaneously really slowly because I
think it's because I woke up at like 5
30 this morning and couldn't go back to
sleep
somehow it was like six or six thirty I
was like [ __ ] it and I just got up and
so I started like working and stuff so
by the time it was new and I was just
like I was like [ __ ] man I've already
done like a full work day I wish
you know what I mean got my hand let go
you got claws my hand oh oh well that's
your fault for putting that down there
like that yeah okay
damn
she got me yeah hooked me with a claw
she didn't realize it
she's like why you put your hand there
daddy I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] it up wow
well I had the mouse oh I was playing
with the mouse and she grabbed my hand
she's like why you take my mouth don't
take my mouth but I couldn't yank it
away yeah man it made it worse so I just
had to wait for her to let go he's going
yeah it's right above the right above
the nail too like like two millimeters
above the damn fingernail yikes yeah it
hurt
John Smith said it's true I'm in my 40s
and years are flying by yeah long-term
prisoners say the seconds drag but the
decades fly by yeah that makes sense I
get that yeah Sebastian says I'm in my
50s and I feel it yeah I'm gonna be 50
uh actually a week from today
next Monday next Monday yeah it's my
birthday so we're gonna have to do we'll
have to do a special birthday episode of
Haunting no [ __ ] I don't know I don't
know like which one it's gonna be is
there any is there is there any haunting
episode that has like a birthday on it I
don't know I don't remember I've seen so
many but that would be like funny if we
did that I can't remember I can't either
I'll I'll look it up I'll we have till
next week to figure that out but yeah
the one we're doing today is the calling
which is season four episode three this
is one that somebody recommended
a few weeks ago and I thought that they
were bricks I didn't know if they were
just like recommended because they just
kind of said the name of it like without
any context so I wasn't sure if they
were just like recommending like hey do
this one or if they were saying that
that was the one that you were talking
about with the slave guy and all that
stuff which like I said wasn't what that
was called that was called Demon's
revenge and that was what we did last
week so the calling is uh completely
different
completely different Jon Smith said how
long until people are spotting the
Queen's ghost I'm surprised nobody said
that they've seen it already you know
what I mean yeah
[Laughter]
you want I'll be the first I mean it
won't be true but I can say anything
[Laughter]
you can only see her up in England
you don't know that I mean maybe up
there maybe she wanted to like vacation
in Florida and so that's where her ghost
is gonna hang out that's my story and
I'm sticking to it okay
I don't want to see her she's been
around forever
yeah but maybe maybe she would be like
young and hot
she went Nana when she was young come on
well no I'm just saying but yeah you
know if you got to choose like your
ghost form you'd think that you would
choose like your hottest time period
according to the stories that's not what
happens
[Music]
a lot of hags have been seen as ghosts
maybe they chose to look like that
because it was scarier because I kind of
feel like I'd be tempted to go that
route too okay uh Robert said you're
gonna be 50. I don't believe it yeah
neither do I sometimes but yep only I
have I only have a week left of being in
my 40s and then I'll be in my 50s yeah
40s 40 hits and then I'll send 50. bam
it's instant
soon you die
uh it doesn't matter
It's All Temporary here we go with the
nihilism again no it doesn't matter um
it's only temporary anyway Nicholas says
Ghost Soldier has a birthday the one
where the woman becomes obsessed with
the picture remember that's his brother
maybe we should do that one yeah I
remember that being a pretty good
episode remember being all right yeah
that was pretty good
yeah that wasn't one of my favorites but
it was it was it was pretty good yeah it
was one that I remembered because it was
like a little bit different because it
had the thing I kind of like some of the
ones that have like cursed objects kind
of action on it yeah like a cursed
painting or well wait divic box that
wasn't the haunting was it that was
paranormal way yes we bought uh two or
the newer Seasons
um
I was pissed that you could only get
digital versions I said man I'd like to
get that on disk but now that I've seen
two seasons of them I was like no I
don't want that they are too glad they
eat their [ __ ] yeah they're not made
poorly it's just the stories suck
they're um
they're not about ghosts
mostly no mostly not about ghosts yeah
they're trying to Branch off into new
[ __ ] and the seasons are very short they
have like six episodes in them they're
not long Seasons I don't even remember
it like did what'd it be what did we buy
like season eight there's eight and nine
I think which season eight was mostly
okay and then we tried to buy nine and
ten but they weren't available so then I
think he bought 11. they're like 11 or
12. and then we started watching 11 that
one most of them were just kind of dumb
or like not well the thing that we
noticed I don't remember if I brought
this up before but the thing that we
noticed that
um kind of made it not as good like Not
only was where the story is not as good
and didn't really have a lot of just
like haunted house or possession type
stuff they were trying to go off in like
silly directions like I said mummies and
all that kind of crap yeah mummies and
yeah so there's like all kind of weird
[ __ ] like haunted masks and I'm just
kind of like okay whatever that's right
but um one thing that I noticed is that
they seem to and I'm guessing that this
was a money-saving Enterprise that they
don't they clearly don't shoot as much
footage because they'll do like the
segment and then it'll go to like
commercial but obviously it doesn't get
a commercial because we bought it but
then it comes right back and then it
like like spends one or two minutes like
recapping the Recaps along what you just
saw and it's like because I feel like on
the old shows it did kind of a recap but
it just did like a boop boop boop boop
boop like little collage of images that
took like a second like 10 seconds
they're just like yeah yeah here's what
you we've seen now we're moving on
whereas like the new ones it's just kind
of like yeah it's just kind of like one
or two minutes of like here's the [ __ ]
that you just saw like 30 seconds ago
here it is again you know what I mean
like with the same footage
yeah intuitous recap it just they just
try to flesh it out and Yeah and and the
uh
the uh the scores are more generic
they're more like you could tell they're
kind of a little bit more canned feeling
to them
yeah I wonder what there's maybe it's
not the same person like doing or
they're reusing old stuff and just kind
of patching it in there maybe some of it
didn't seem to fit
yeah I don't know I just didn't like it
but they put folk song in in one of them
yeah that's right that's right that was
when she was talking about what going to
Thailand no India India that's right
it's just I kind of thought they were
just trying to make it seem like oh
because we're doing one that's in India
and like a ghost followed her back yeah
from India so we're trying to give it
that India flavor they're not as tight
yeah they're not as tight they're
they're not like little little movies
like these are these are like little
movies yeah movies that are that have
voice over and you know narration and uh
kind of like a documentary it's a
documentary but in a movie form no way
to describe it
it's a horror movie made to feel like a
documentary to make it seem like it's
something that actually happened
whether it did or not that's part of the
show you know we addressed that in these
little episodes whether or not we think
it happened
what do you think about this one or
would that be a spoiler alert spoiler
usually you're all about like just uh uh
saying all the [ __ ] up front you don't
that's why I'm just asking yeah see she
presses me and then she goes well you
don't have to
this one
has some paranormal investigators
involved in it that did collect some
evidence
so I think there might have been
something to this one
it's not as impressive as some of the
other ones but then again
I mean like the tails are not as
impressive right the like the phenomena
that was reported isn't quite as
impressive
but evidently according to the to to uh
to the investigators she passed a few
tests
about picking picking names out of a
lineup and picking faces out of a lineup
without any prompting I wouldn't dare
that'd be easy to fake uh you know what
I mean if you took collude to make a
good case but
the claims aren't [ __ ] outlandish no
not really not really and well the thing
about this one is that this one mostly
just revolved around her like the lady
and I don't really remember there being
any particular like physical
manifestations like nothing was like
thrown around or like hearing you know
thumping or anything like that it just
seemed like mostly her seeing and
hearing things and I don't think anybody
else did she had a psychic uh ability to
um
see the dead or see things that had
happened in the past to the dead or
whatever she could she was kind of like
I guess you'd call a medium
but she didn't have to be in a trance
she could just pick it up
she was like okay in the Sixth Sense
kind of kid in the Sixth Sense yep that
would kind of suck honestly because
you'd think that there'd be [ __ ]
ghosts everywhere If ghosts exist then
they'd be all over the [ __ ] place and
if you could actually see him all the
time man you know she was having fun as
a kid didn't scare him I guess that's
her dad that was a dick about it
yeah her dad was really addictive so you
know um I don't think it'd be a problem
you know you might be able to put that
to good use
that'd be a good survival skill
that's true yeah
but I kind of feel like like I said if
you could you'd have to selectively see
ghosts though because if you saw all the
ghosts
then it would probably just be too many
and it would just be like constant
[ __ ] well your subconscious handles
that I guess so and filters out Tom's
got this all figured out you got it all
figured out of course well I've had
phenomena like this happen
so you know your subconscious would
filter out unimportant ones you'd never
see those it was just the ones that were
more relevant to the time and place that
you were in you you might become aware
of those you know
yeah I guess so sure uh raise the
brain's fantastic it's magical
it's a quantum computer
okay I have a magical brain yeah it's a
quantum computer it can do [ __ ]
fantastic stuff part of it is in another
dimension part of it is in another
dimension we would call the spirit Realm
slightly outside of space-time continuum
it's where you go when you actually
project part of your mind's in there but
it's not your conscious being it's
mostly your unconscious kind of like
jungian Carl Jung's got Cosmic
unconscious kind of deal
yeah we're all going to like
messing around with all the [ __ ]
everyone else's Consciousness
Consciousness is yeah
we're all playing in the yard Quantum
radio sure Quantum Internet
hahaha
so yeah we got lots and lots of people
in here it looks like all of our
regulars are here you want to start on
the episode and you can just kind of
I actually did take notes while I was
watching the episode again last night so
all I had to do today was type them over
so I didn't actually have to watch it
twice but I remembered this one and the
lady that's in this God damn it I meant
to look up that actress's name because
the lady that's in this one that like
plays the main woman
um she's been in a bunch of episodes
but I can't remember what the other ones
were because I meant to look up our IMDb
she's just in a [ __ ] but she's like in a
whole bunch of them and she's I think
she I kind of feel like she's been in
more of them than any of the other
actors because didn't um didn't like uh
where is that raccoon guy wasn't he in
another one he was in a few I thought he
was in a few too but this lady was in
like a [ __ ] ton of episodes like she was
in at least four or five of them I'm
pretty sure
but yeah so she's in this one too but
like I said I meant to look it up
because I was like trying to figure out
I'm trying to remember like what um what
other episode she was in but I forgot so
you know there we go all right gotta be
a 20 of them so well I don't know about
20 but I was gonna say maybe like five
of them she's real familiar
and that one girl that was in the one we
did the other day she was in a couple of
them too yeah and like I said I
remembered her because she kind of
looked like one of my cousins when she
was a kid so she stood out but I don't
know why but This Woman's like being a
[ __ ] out of him so yeah like I said
this is season I think it's season four
episode three I want to say like so I
keep wanting to say it's season three
episode four but it's not I'm pretty
sure it's season four now this is
another one
I'm gonna say right now that it's like
it wasn't really I couldn't really find
any outside information about this
particular case or this particular woman
or anything like that because this was
another one where the real people
um appeared in Shadow and uh so
consequently we're not using their real
names they did have a couple of
paranormal investigators on there who
showed their faces and they said what
their names are but I'll get into that
in a little bit because I couldn't
really find either one of them
um but I'm not really sure how to spell
that one guy's last name and so I tried
to like look for it but nothing was
coming up so I don't really know if he's
got a group or I don't really know
so all right this was quite a while ago
yeah I mean this episode went into first
air 2004. I think it was two I thought
it's either 2004 or 2007 it's probably
2000.4 yeah maybe it did like I said it
was far away so I couldn't really tell
because it says on the disk because this
we have this on the disk and it'll have
it has three or four episodes on each
disk and then it'll say first aired blah
blah and yeah I couldn't tell if it was
2004 or 2007. okay so this one actually
starts out in New Jersey in the fall of
1974.
now there's a cop named uh Bill Mallory
not his real name apparently
and he's in a car with his five-year-old
daughter Rebecca who was kind of the
main focus of our thing here also not
her real name I'm presuming
um so Rebecca has been seeing the ghost
of her great grandfather who she calls
pop pop ever since he died and it's like
not even a big deal to her she just like
sees him like
like you would see a living person and
she just like talks to him and it's like
it's no thing kind of like to have that
girl used to see Mr Gordy
yeah right
if you guys have seen the pilot that's a
good episode
Julian Pope said I think her name is
Kelly Davis that actress she's also in
Cobra Kai on Netflix is she I didn't
notice that I didn't notice her either
and you'd think that we'd be like hey is
that lady for my hunting she looks like
Jeffrey Combs little sister
if Jeffrey calms that little sister
would be her
put some glasses on her she had glasses
on it because man she looks like Jeffrey
Carlos for [ __ ] with Herbert West
that you're reanimate
kind of well like
when Jeffrey comes was young
but yeah we were talking about that last
night he said she looked like Jeffrey
Combs yeah so this one particular night
apparently
but the dad's driving yeah obviously the
five-year-old kid isn't driving but so
the little girl is in the front seat of
the back seat I don't know
and uh the car pulls up at a red light
behind this dude on a motorcycle
now uh Rebecca like she says that pop
pop or the ghost of her great grandpa is
in the back seat and says hey tell your
dad don't go like when the light turns
green just wait
and so Rebecca says um you should wait
like when the lights she doesn't say
like what how she knows that she just
says um you know don't go yet so her dad
doesn't go and then like the um
motorcycle guy like goes into the
intersection there was a big huge wreck
so the dad is like wigging out and she's
kind of wigging out because she sees
like the motors I don't think the
motorcycle guy was killed or anything
but he looked like kind of [ __ ] up and
um dad's like well how did you know that
like that that I should wait and she
said pop pop told me like he was in the
car
now dad
um he doesn't really believe any of this
psychic nonsense and there's kind of a
scene of the little girl kind of sitting
over here in the living room and then
like the mom and dad like arguing about
it and the dad like I said you know
these are not the real people obviously
and the um the real Rebecca is in Shadow
so I don't actually know what her real
name is so I don't really know if this
is how it actually was or just how she
perceived it but the mom and dad are
kind of like fighting about it and the
dad is being a real douche about just
like look this is she's too old to have
imaginary friends or didn't he say
something like that I'm like she's five
that's too old to have imaginary friends
a lot of kids have imaginary friends
like older than that for sure
but so yeah he's being like a real
douche about it but she's like yeah but
like in I don't know if she was talking
about pop pop the great grandfather or
the or somebody else in the family but
she said oh somebody else in the family
also could also see dead people
apparently or could psychically
communicate with dead people it's like
maybe she
um you know inherited that trait or
whatever and he just did whatever
[ __ ] uh then he just like doesn't
believe any of it right
what no I'm just saying that
even though Stephen King was a fiction
writer he did a lot of really good
research and he would he would read
about what was happening out in
California in places like UCLA and in
their parapsychology Department
and um
a good way to describe all this stuff
it's pretty much the way
Mr Halloran describes it in The Shining
okay
it's like pictures in a book it's not
real
certain places have some that's kind of
like shining you know uh sometimes bad
things can happen and and traces are
left behind kind of like burnt toast
just because you see a ghost doesn't
mean that that ghost is there
it's like pictures in the book
you know what I mean that person may
have been in that area in the past but
that soul may not necessarily be there
even though you can interact with it but
it's kind of like a
hologram
uh with uh and it's kind of like the
Hologram and you're having like a dream
like episode where you can actually
interact with it
but it's not there
although it may be able to hurt you
which that's what happens in the book
The Shining with Danny yeah
he'd see stuff that happened it would
interact with him it could sometimes
touch him and hurt him but it wasn't
really there those Souls weren't there
maybe
but it would depend depend on the
situation
in some places
shine or have something like Shining
in Star Wars terminology would say it
was a place that was strong with the
dark side
I believe all that because I've
experienced things like that if not
exactly that sometimes sometimes that
sometimes just stuff kind of like that
and have an nde or near-death experience
you can kind of see from another
perspective slightly how things like
this
are pro probably real
I'm not going to say could be real I
could see how certain things could exist
based on things that other things that I
know exist
so I don't know I'm just throwing that
in there
her seeing these ghosts doesn't
necessarily means that those ghosts are
there doing what it is that she sees at
that particular time it's like a picture
book
yeah it could be although like I said if
any of this is true like the fact that a
great grandpa there knew that there was
going to be a wreck
that would seem to uh indicate that he
was interacting with her in real time it
might be her psychic abilities and it
just used this pop pop as a as an avatar
in the same way Danny's shining had the
Avatar of Tony there was no Tony he's
the little boy who lives yeah there was
no tone Tony was away I love that it was
Tony was away for Danny to explain his
abilities to himself
without having to take direct
responsibility for him
might be the same with this girl
it's her doing this but her version of
Tony is modeled after her her
grandfather or with a great grandfather
Yeah I think it was great I think it was
great grandfather right so her I think
it was her mom's grandfather Yeah Pop
Pop's probably long gone
but she's keeping kind of an internal
Avatar of him
yeah to help her explain what's
happening
to herself in other words it's her like
super ego has the has the image is built
in the image of
pop-up
but yeah the mom says to the dad that
you know Pop I think I think she's
talking about pop pop like that which
would be her grandfather I guess and
she's saying that he knew exactly how he
was gonna die like he told the whole
family hey I'm out of here like I'm not
gonna be around after the weekend and
they said that she that he died that
Saturday like he knew exactly when he
was gonna die and so that he always had
that power too so they're thinking that
maybe she inherited it and um so like I
said Rebecca meanwhile doesn't think
it's weird at all because she sees pop
pop all the time it's like they're
sitting in a room playing and all kind
of stuff and she just like is always
talking to him but she didn't think it
was weird
so then they jump ahead like a year
later when she's six and Rebecca is
walking down the street with her mom and
dad and then she sees a guy uh sitting
on some steps like in front of an
apartment building and she stops to talk
to him and he says hi what's your name
my name is Carl blah blah and so she
starts talking to him and then they show
that she's talking to nobody uh and her
dad gets super super aggro about it I
mean I mean really I know this is actors
like I said but it seemed like a a
drastic overreaction I'm just saying it
was a drastic overreaction he gets like
really really mad he's yelling at her
look there's nobody there
um if you're really seeing things then
you should just block it all out because
basically I'm sick of dealing with it
and you're a weird kid and I'm not
having it so uh you know he makes the
poor little kid cry and she's like okay
I'll try to like do that and so then
they kind of interview the real woman
like in Shadow and she says so basically
after that episode she's like so from
the age of six or seven onward I learned
to either like block out the settings
like just if I saw the [ __ ] I would just
ignore it
um or if I couldn't ignore it then I
would just keep the [ __ ] to myself
because I figured that my dad was gonna
yell at me and that I would get in
trouble so I was like that's really sad
but okay
uh she said she did that all throughout
her teenage years and into her 20s and
kind of got used to doing that you know
what I mean
so they said she got married in 1995 and
had a couple kids but then had like a
really bad like an acrimonious divorce
uh several years later
now in 2002 she moves to Southeastern
Virginia from New Jersey presumably uh
with her two kids now at this point she
has a son that's seven on the show they
called him Tim and uh you know she has a
five-year-old daughter named Hannah
again probably not their real names
obviously because she's not using hers
the kids don't really factor into it all
that much so it doesn't really matter if
you know what their names are
so since she was a single mom and she
was like working really long hours I
don't think if they did they say what
she did was she a nurse or something
like I don't remember if they said what
she did
um I didn't write it down anyway so
she's like since she was so busy all the
time she found it a lot easier to block
out the spirit sightings because
apparently like from what she was saying
it sounded like she always had them but
she just gotten to a point where she's
just like nope not seeing that you know
what I mean like she was able to like
kind of shut it out a little bit
so she was doing some charity work she
said at some children's hospital when
she meets this dude named Daniel Lennox
now he was on this is obviously not his
real name either he was on the show too
but also in Shadow I think they said he
was a dentist and he said I don't know I
just for some reason I thought this was
funny but he said when he met her
um at this conference or whatever he was
engaged to somebody else but then like
when he met Rebecca it's like they just
like hit it off right away so he just
like broke off the engagement with the
other chick
so him and Rebecca got married like
really quickly I don't know how quickly
but quickly they said and they moved
into this big new house and they start
talking about having another kid and
everything's like this big fairy tale
family yada yada
now immediately though
Rebecca starts kind of feeling a bit
weirded out in the new house now on the
show they actually showed her when she
first comes in there like when they
first move in like that she heard a
child giggling now she didn't say that
in that interview so I don't know if
that's true or not now but she did say
that she heard that like later on like
during those events so I'm assuming
they're just like extrapolating that she
came in and heard that
so a few weeks after that she says she
was out working in the yard and then she
looks over and she sees this Spooky
Little Ghost Boy kind of standing in the
grass
now she tries to block it out because
she said it was pretty scary and you
know at this point like I said she's
kind of gotten used to blocking stuff
out by now but for some reason she's
like she couldn't block this one out and
uh so she starts to think that maybe uh
stuff might be ramping up or coming back
like in like with a Vengeance or
whatever and kind of threatening this
whole nice normal life that she's
constructed for herself with her new
family and whatnot
so Rebecca doesn't tell Daniel about the
ghost uh and she also obviously doesn't
tell him that she's been seeing ghosts
since she was a little kid
um you know obviously for obvious
reasons because she's afraid that that
he'll think she's a nut
so she tries to keep everything normal
but she keeps seeing the ghost kid still
like at one point she goes out in the
backyard and she sees the creepy little
kid like standing by the picnic table in
the backyard like her daughter is
sitting at the table and doesn't see him
but she comes out and he's standing
there and she's just like oh [ __ ] and
she like freaks out and makes the
daughter come inside
so and the daughter's like what the [ __ ]
mom you know what I mean like she didn't
really but that's what I was thinking so
then after that she makes the daughter
come in the house and then like um then
she sees the ghost boy in the house like
just walking down the hallway like dude
like that
so she's basically like okay well I
guess I'm just gonna see this kid
everywhere now but
um and I guess I just have to accept
that fact but I'm still not gonna tell
anybody about it now her husband knows
probably something's up with her but
doesn't really press the issue like
doesn't because she does obviously
doesn't want to tell him what's going on
so he's just kind of like okay well
whenever you want to tell me you'll tell
me and I'll just like back off you
now shortly after this the TV keeps
coming on by itself and it's always
cartoons I don't know if that's what it
was really like or not
so Rebecca said she kept seeing this
damn kid like pretty much every day like
as a ghost kid
so finally like the TV keeps coming on
she keeps seeing the kid and everything
like that so she shouts at the ghost kid
just like stop it and I think she tells
him to like go away and then she said
she immediately felt really bad because
she's like you know I know it's a ghost
and everything but that's still a kid
you know what I mean so it's kind of
shitty hey get the [ __ ] out of here you
little you ghostly little brat but yeah
so she said she felt really bad about it
now later on that night while she's in
bed
her blanket kind of gets tugged some and
it just like wakes her up but of course
she looks around and there's nobody in
the room right
and then apparently the covers are
pulled like all the way off and she said
she started to feel a weird pressure on
her leg
so when she looks at her leg she sees
what appears to be a child-sized bite
mark it looked like it was on her calf
like on the side of her calf
she also hears the boy giggling but she
made a point to say the giggling wasn't
Sinister necessarily it was just like a
kid giggling like almost like a
mischievous or something like that
so Rebecca finally goes in the other
room and shows Daniel the bite marks and
he's just like well what did one of the
kids bite you because he's like he was a
dentist so he was just kind of like he's
like yeah that's a kid's bite mark all
right um he's they said you could even
see like the top four teeth were all
like crooked you know what I mean like a
kid's teeth would be
and so basically she's like no you know
our living kids didn't do this there's a
ghost kid in the house and I've been
seeing him for a long time and the
little [ __ ] bit me
so he's pretty incredulous about this I
guess as you would be but to his credit
he does actually believe her
um pretty much right away
and so he takes a picture of the bite
mark
and uh but Rebecca doesn't tell him she
does tell him about the ghost boy but
she doesn't tell him that she's been
seeing ghosts her whole life though and
that she's been trying to like suppress
the gift all this time
So Daniel wants to contact the
paranormal investigators and Rebecca
doesn't really want to do that because
she's like I was just kind of hoping
that all of this would go away you know
what I mean it was just seemed like too
much trouble
um but Daniel is just kind of like he's
he's reading all these paranormal
websites I love like there's always one
part in all of these episodes where
somebody's like and then they went to
the internet and like looked up
paranormal stuff and so everybody in the
world that has seen a single horror
movie like knows all of the stuff like
all about sage and all this like
everybody knows that now you don't have
to look on the internet to like how to
get rid of ghosts you know what I mean
it's just kind of like I don't know it's
it's almost kind of a thing where like
you know how like an old vampire movies
they're always kind of like oh we pull
out this old book and it's like this is
vampires and it's garlic i'm like [ __ ]
everybody knows that everybody so I just
you wouldn't you don't have to look it
up so I kind of feel like it was the
same kind of thing that he had to look
up on the on the Paranormal website to
like figure out what to do uh I was just
like wave some Sage around that's what
they always do so um but well actually
this was kind of a little bit different
because this paranormal website I guess
they said well why don't you just yell
at the ghost to go away because
sometimes that's all it takes you know
if you have some kind of like ghost
that's
you know because it was kind of a wimp
and he'll just be like oh okay sorry
didn't mean to bother you and he'll just
leave
so he shouts at the ghost to go away
hoping that will solve the problem
now they end up calling this place
called the center for paranormal
research and investigation which is
apparently still around I looked at
their website
um but yeah so I I got confused because
I don't know this first paranormal woman
that came
I couldn't I didn't know if the second
guy that came like the um guy and the
woman that came later that did like more
of an investigation type deal I don't
know if they were affiliated with this
first group like I thought they were
from the show but then when I was like
looking it up I was like well I looked
on their website and no [ __ ] on that
website look looks anything like those
other two people that they were talking
about so I'm thinking maybe these second
two people were from another group all
right you know what I'm saying maybe I
don't I don't know I didn't they weren't
real clear on that on the show or either
that or I didn't really get it so I
don't know but the first one they call
is the center for paranormal research
and investigation which is in Richmond
Virginia or near Richmond Virginia
so a week later I don't think a whole
team came I think just one woman came
because she just came like for the you
know initial assessment or whatever like
to see what was going on
now so she gets there and Rebecca who
was not real down with this idea so she
just kind of tries to downplay
everything oh it you know it wasn't
really that big a deal
um you know I just kind of saw this boy
but it's nothing it's like I'm sure
it'll be fine blah blah she doesn't
really want to like exacerbate it and
she doesn't want to get into her whole
history with seeing ghosts and [ __ ] like
that and I think she doesn't really want
Daniel to know any of this stuff so
she's really really trying to like keep
it on the down low and she's just kind
of like yeah yeah it's fine it'll be
fine and Daniel was just sitting there
going you know here she is talking to
this lady and she's was freaking out
about it a week ago but now she's being
like no it's fine like don't worry about
it so um the investigator I guess since
she's not getting much info out of
Rebecca she basically shrugs and says ah
well maybe the ghosts will go away on
its own you know maybe everything will
work out and it'll be fine
so then they said two weeks went by with
no activity
and Rebecca kind of forgets about it
but then sorry I just left I just looked
at her at the chat and I saw blue and OJ
say ghost kid talk about pop pop pop
music New York London Paris Munich but
yeah so um I just saw that like I had to
laugh
um and we got a new person new person
what's up Anna evening from Canada
newbie here well hello welcome we do we
do these every Monday I mean we do a
show almost every day but we do the
haunting shows on Monday
so um so yeah maybe the ghost will go
away on its own bye
two weeks go by no activity
uh and then Rebecca's like phew well
maybe that's over
but then she's like standing at the
kitchen window like doing the dishes or
whatever and she sees another ghost
standing out in the yard like this one's
a grown man like but kind of wearing
clothes that look like you know a few
decades ago like
and while she's standing there in the
kitchen she said she heard a bunch of
voice like two voices I think she said
it sounded like two voices that sounded
like two guys shouting and also
something that sounds like a plane
engine like a plane engine and then a
crash
so she's kind of freaking out and Daniel
Comes running into the kitchen and
apparently it's really loud to her
because she's like screaming like I
can't we can't you can't hear that you
can't hear that and he's like yeah I
don't hear that
um and she's like wow I must look like a
real [ __ ] Looney Tune
um but she said yeah I heard all this
noise she says that she couldn't pick
out some of what they said but she said
she definitely heard P51 Mustang and she
says that and then Daniel is actually
surprised because he's like oh well
those were planes used in World War II
and he didn't think that Rebecca knew
anything about that so the fact that she
came up with that just out of the blue
was kind of weirded him out because
she said she could hear it and he could
immediately made me think that it was
something she was accessing it wasn't a
it's an internal phenomenon in this case
not something external although it can't
be both depending on what the situation
is but in this particular thing she's
picking up something out of the
environment
and maybe it's manifesting to her if
she's actually seeing what she's saying
she's saying maybe it is manifesting to
her as
a person seeing it she's picking up
information and and her brain the brain
then interprets it as a 3D moving
hologram message you can even interact
with it
um it's not there
but all that information is true it's
something from the past
a lot of it I think has to do with like
I said what Mr Halloran said some places
uh have something kind of like Shining
and uh things happen that sometimes
leaves residue behind kind of like burnt
toast so she's picking up the residue of
something that happened a long time ago
in a place and she's seeing this in
places that are strong with the dark
side I guess you could say
places that have a shine to them or
something that's like shine
and her brain picks it up and sees it as
a 3D message
you can even interact with it help me
it'll be one you're my only yeah like
that
like that but it's some kind of quantum
information that the mind unravels and
sees it as an experience kind of like a
dream
it's not there but all the information
in it would be real you'd see how the
person look would look like you could
have a conversation with them you could
get real information from them it may
not be real complicated but you know
basic information you'd be able to pick
it up that's what I think is happening
in this particular case
that would be kind of neat but also kind
of horrifying at the same time
I mean I guess if you if you had had
that since childhood it wouldn't seem
all that weird to you because that would
just be like your experiences not too
far removed from not too far removed
from animal
abilities like
dogs and scent they could smell
something smell another dog's piss and
know everything a damn about the dog
imagine if there's something like a
psychic version of that where your mind
picks up Quantum particles and your mind
is probably this Quantum Cloud kind of
like Stuart hammeroff says it picks up
this Quantum particles and you're now
experiencing a hologram it's Interactive
kind of like
and you you probably interpret it as a
vision and it's kind of a dream like you
know but it's all accurate information
you can even talk to it
kind of like Superman in The Fortress of
Solitude talking to his dad
you know like that
yeah like that was long gone that would
be kind of cool but it's like that
but like I said I'm guessing if you grew
up like that you'd probably be used to
it after a while like it wouldn't be
scary after a while I would think
um even in even like I said I like to
use I like to use terminology that you
guys can relate to and
like Stephen King stuff and Star Wars
stuff
you know
I'll I'll quote stuff that comes out of
fiction but it's based in things that
really happened you know what I mean
King knew about parapsychology he was
getting this from other people he wasn't
making this up himself
same with Lucas
you got that chip you got that [ __ ] from
Joseph Campbell
yeah well I mean I kind of feel like a
lot of fiction writers yeah get stuff
from there and Campbell got all that
from
Buddhism
and German philosophy
and it's talking about uh
she says I brought a family of four home
with a silver tea service I got at a
free store
and uh Blair day dude said of course the
tea service is cursed and it said not
cursed it was a prized family possession
and they were hurt it was given away
like trash they saw I took care of it
and they left a week later okay that's
kind of cool they're just kind of like
we want to make sure that like y'all are
gonna take care of that [ __ ] you know
what I mean that's our favorite thing
I can see that
uh all right so
yeah so World War II plane all right now
so Rebecca like I said she's keep seeing
this stuff and she's starting to get
more and more withdrawn because like I
said she doesn't really want to tell
Daniel any more about it and Daniel like
uh like many a man on this show is upset
that he can't just like fix it because
they always want they and they a couple
of them have actually said that too like
they just wanted to he said that on the
show that he's like I was just upset
that I couldn't just like fix it because
the paranormal thing we've talked about
this a lot because we've talked about
this on the um the one with uh with the
with your friend Ed Dunham the Deltona
one yeah and um and actually an episode
we watched the other day I don't
remember if we talked about it or not
but um the guy actually said on there
something that we had said like has a as
a joke like on a previous show that the
guys like they don't know how to deal
with the get with the ghost because they
can't punch it yeah
I just thought that was funny it's like
well we can't I can't punch it and throw
it out the house so I'm out of options I
don't really know what to do so yeah I'm
gonna quote some more King and actually
from the book
uh if I remember correctly with [ __ ]
that Halloran said
reason why this happens to dudes
who get pissed off and they can't punch
it
hollering in one part of the book says
something that's true
and I found it to be true too
pretty much everybody shines
most people only shine a little bit
a lot of people shine pretty good all
right and most of them don't know that
they do okay
some people shine a lot
in my experience it's always kids
going through
pubertying sometimes or you know between
10
and 14.
that's when most people Shine the
brightest
and that's the time when actually things
can manifest under right circumstances
with the right kid
it's rare to get
an adult that can shine like that
some can but it's very rare
and and the phenomenon is going to be a
lot different
with an older person
where the young persons can be a lot
more chaotic
a lot more out of control
uh more emotional
[Music]
the only people that think don't shine
there's something wrong with them
either physically or mentally
you can kind of see it okay like
when I'm listening to interviews of
serial killers and I said they're
lizard-like and they kind of have that
that uh pathological liar
voice pattern to them those people don't
shine at all
it's like a black hole of this it's like
a non-inity
like there's no soul
that's what it feels like to me
yeah I mean they definitely do uh come
across like that yeah they don't even
come across as evil to me they're just
coming no they don't they come across as
nothing
yeah I get what you're saying yeah they
just come across as like a void yeah
like a robot yeah
all right yeah not like a person right
or not not like someone that's not fully
there yeah I guess the way a normal
human is yeah a truly evil person can
shine
all right they can have a lot of talent
and this goes back to things that
Friedrich Nietzsche and Arthur
schopenhauer
said
this you can take a great person and if
you [ __ ] beat him up and torture them
enough
they can turn into quite a monster
but they have a lot of willpower and a
lot of uh and they could do a lot of
damage but they're very rare when you
have a person like that and it's a lot
of times is that they always think
they're doing good
you know what I mean very different
Sarah Killers know they're not doing
good
yeah they just don't they just don't
give a [ __ ] yeah a truly evil person
thinks that what they're doing is good
that they are fighting evil all right
but they might have it kind of twisted
around
or they have a very different view you
know but there's a lot of and some of
some people that shine
that are kind of a weird mixture
ones that I kind of like which are kind
of like Warrior types
like
anytime I hear
recordings of
Patton George Patton and I know George
Patton knew about the Paranormal he was
into that okay I can feel a guy who
shied and he was a good great leader
also Eisenhower not Eisen what's his
name um
MacArthur MacArthur had a lot of shine
to him
they weren't good men but they were
great they were very great
they were kind of the warlord types
so just just giving you examples and it
makes me think that guys
like Washington we're probably like that
too
not really good but they weren't evil
either they were just great
sometimes great could be terrible it all
depends on your point of view if you're
fighting them you don't want to fight
them okay they'll kill you you know so
differing opinions that will cost you
with those kind of people
sorry I was just thinking when you were
talking about how um how evil people
like think that they're doing good and
stuff I was thinking of that
um what the [ __ ] was that British uh
sketch show that had that whole sketch
on there about the two Nazi soldiers
being like are we the baddies
like they just realized it yeah it was
super super funny well no that was like
I know but that's exactly well that's
why it was funny that's what I mean
that's why yeah a lot of a lot of these
dumb kids today look at that what
happened in World War II and they think
that they that that the Germans thought
they were bad no they thought they were
the ultimate good they saw themselves as
fighting evil
and everything that they were doing was
to keep their people safe from people
that were trying to hurt them
and they were killing people whole
families because they thought that they
were
diseased dirty Bad Evil trying to hurt
them that they wouldn't share that kind
of stuff
the people that couldn't be socialist
people that couldn't be morally right
they were cleaning up their place
getting rid of garbage
you got to be real careful with
sanctimony
if you if you think you're better than
other people in sanctimonious and see
other people it's just evil
bad people you'll kill them
and there's really just a difference of
an opinion even Obi-Wan said many of the
truths that we cling to often depend
upon a certain point of view
and morality is usually a point of view
does it mean to be immoral though
just that you have to have empathy you
have to be able to you have to have
what's called strategic empathy if
you're at war with a person
you have to be able to see the reality
that they see if not you'll never find
peace
you'll never be able to beat that person
either because you won't be able to
predict them because you don't
understand their value system
so you have to understand who it is
you're fighting always you have to have
empathy for them
Mark said Patton Road at length he was a
reincarnated Roman soldier
a lot of things too
he believed in Souls
he was a cool dude
because book Wars I know it wore as I
knew it was really good really good book
yeah we should maybe do a show about him
yeah he was good dude
he uh spent a lot of of his own money to
keep his tanks running in between Wars
it was a very unusual officer kind of an
officer from another era kind of like he
was kind of like somebody out of the
1700s
he wasn't a a corporate
type officer that I came up with in
service
kind of an artist type
officer although here's another thing
there's some myth to patent
Patton did good [ __ ] but there were a
lot of U.S generals like that
he just tended to get the spotlight
because he was an oddball he did do some
cool missions though you know his
armored unit was good
but there were a lot of them like that
all right so you want to get back to the
show okay here we go
so uh so where did we get distracted
okay so uh Daniel's upset that we can't
he can't fix it he can't punch the ghost
yeah you know what I mean he didn't
really seem like he wanted to punch the
ghost he just kind of wanted to fix the
problem because obviously his wife was
uh was upset
um and she's denying it which I think is
kind of like worrying him some because
it's like one day she's they're out in
the yard and he's like she very very
clearly saw something like a ghost like
standing there and he's like what hey do
you see something what are you saying
she's like nope don't see anything nope
nope nope and she just like would not
you know she just wouldn't like cop to
it and so I think he was starting to get
worried about it
um and he but she was getting she said
she was getting more and more like upset
and like starting to lose her mind and
she's like man if I told Daniel all the
[ __ ] that was going on he'd think I was
a nut and all this other kind of stuff
so uh at one point not too long into
this like Daniel and Rebecca take this
day trip to Williamsburg like as a kind
of like just mini vacation or whatever
but Rebecca is just really not having a
good time she's you know just she's kind
of feels she said she felt like she was
in a downward spiral at this point
now while they're driving home uh Daniel
puts the radio on and Rebecca starts
hearing this old woman's voice coming
through the car radio
and of course Daniel can't hear it so
she says she tells Daniel write down the
name Elizabeth Pratt Jones she said it's
this old woman talking and she's like
this woman is saying all kind of stuff
about her property being stolen from her
um you know her slaves were taken and
she wasn't paid for them that kind of
stuff
so at this point Daniel finally gets to
the thing he's like man he's like she
has been like maybe seeing ghosts like
for a lot longer than she admitted to
because like I said for a long time she
only admitted to seeing that ghost boy
and tried to downplay that but she never
told him that she'd been able to see
ghosts her whole life so he's just now
starting to figure that out uh because
she seemed I don't think she seemed like
kind of calm about it but she's like hey
write down this name yada yada
um so Rebecca said that she later saw
this same old woman in her house
um and kept like repeating the name so
she knew the name and it's getting to
the point she said where she can't sleep
because all these ghosts I guess keep
[ __ ] with her like she keeps hearing
their voices and [ __ ] like that and it's
like keeping her awake so she finally
has had enough and she's like freaking
out and she's like just call now I see
like I said to call the investigators I
don't know if she's saying like call the
different investigators because I think
these were different ones that came or
call back the ones that came before you
know what I mean because it seemed like
it was two different groups but I'm not
entirely sure
so she's like column and I'll tell them
everything and we'll sort this all out
so the next day Daniel talks to a guy
who was on the show and was not in
Shadow or anything like that and I think
they said that his name was Tom varanas
I think they were saying veranis
but I couldn't like but I don't know how
they spelled it like I tried a couple
different spellings but I couldn't
really find anything real quick so
apparently this guy and I don't know if
how true this is but apparently this guy
was a former NASA engineer who now
studies the Paranormal from like a
scientific standpoint so I don't know if
he's like part of that other group
because like I said he wasn't on their
website or anything so he might have
another group that's going on I don't
know or maybe he's just like on his own
so he comes out one evening with another
woman whose name is Melissa kepley now
you might think because usually the the
paranormal investigators come out and
they're like oh and we brought a psychic
this time he didn't bring a psychic he
brought a woman who was a psychologist I
think like or she said she had a
psychology background like that's what
her degree was in how long we've been
going uh an hour
cookie oh yeah we're making a uh two
lasagnas two lasagnas with eggplant so
he's got to go check and make sure that
they're okay but um but yeah so she said
she had a background in Psychology
that's what her degree was in so I guess
that he brings her along I don't know if
he just like doesn't [ __ ] with psychics
and stuff but he brings her along it's
like we're gonna assess
um you know if this woman like what she
tells us like is she does she have any
mental problems or anything like that
which to me seems like what you probably
should be doing I mean the cases that we
wrote about with Steve Mara who's you
know parapsychologist that I wrote a
couple books with
um they do that as well they always do
like a mental health assessment on the
people that are making the claims just
to make sure that this person is not
having some kind of like mental health
issues uh that would be making them you
know see the things they're seeing or
hear this or whatever so that seems like
it's a one of the first thing that that
you should do so I kind of appreciated
that this guy did that so he brings the
psychologist and uh you know they
interview uh they interview Rebecca
so um
he says they're doing well
readings around because they said we
wanted to get a baseline of like you
know what all the magnetic fields around
the house were and see if that was
causing hallucinations or any or any
kind of weird phenomena they said we got
kind of like a couple weird readings
like outside but we figured out it was
just coming from like the air
conditioning unit or whatever so it was
like nothing so it's like they didn't
really get anything weird outside or
inside until uh they get around Rebecca
now so they had an EMF meter and they
had a compass because they said we use
that sometimes too because obviously a
compass can find a magnetic field
so they said we're up there in the
hallway and Rebecca was standing in the
hallway she's like both the EMF meter
and the compass like went ape [ __ ] they
said the compass was just like spinning
around and like the EMF reader was like
going off the charter one of the things
like so it seemed like it was
like like she was making it do that like
that they just went crazy when she was
around now what uh Tom Varina said he
said this is a reading that you would
see like for example when an entity was
present not so much a person they said
they hadn't really seen anything like
that with the instruments reacting like
that to a person I don't know if that's
true or not I don't but you know it
wasn't there like I said so it could be
anything
so um so after that happens they're just
kind of like lady um I think there's
some [ __ ] you're not telling us because
at this point like I said she hadn't
told them about the whole I've been able
to see ghosts in my whole life situation
so um so finally she's like okay
um I'll I'll spill the beans so she
finally spills the beans and uh she's
basically like yeah I've been seeing
ghost my whole entire life and um tells
him the whole story like everything that
she's ever gone through like her whole
entire life and Daniel is like pretty
flabbergasted uh so basically she says
and I don't know if she said this in
real life but that's what the this what
the actress did she said the house isn't
haunted I am that's basically what she
says and she's like and she knew the
whole time and she was like yeah sorry I
didn't tell you blah blah
so
um so then the team like uh Tom and
Melissa they go off to the College of
William and Mary to do some historical
research to see if the stuff that she
said like checked out
so now while that was going on and I
thought this part was interesting
because
it seemed like
I don't know like this one event seemed
kind of like it would be on any other
episode it would have been like the big
climactic thing but on this one they
almost kind of like glided over it a
little bit which I thought was kind of
strange
so something happens in the house that
seems to
I don't know if it really scared Rebecca
and Daniel enough but they did move out
now what they showed on the show it was
like they were in
it seemed like Rebecca like opened the
door to like a room like off the hall or
something like that in the house and
then there was like she saw like some
kind of light and then at the end of the
room or the end of the hall was like a
shadow dude right it was just like a
shadow dude and it was almost like they
portrayed it like a wind but she said it
was just an overwhelming feeling feeling
of like fear and sadness like it was
coming at her like so it was almost kind
of like they were hinting that this was
like an evil entity of some kind or
something
now from what I could determine because
I'm like I'm very careful about how I'm
like now what exactly did they say and
like what did they mean by that because
I know like they show stuff on the show
and that's not always hey it's Pokey hi
Pokey look you're on the show she's like
I don't care she's like I don't care I
don't want her she's gonna jump down I
don't want to be on the lap I only be on
the lap for a couple of minutes oh no
actually she's been she's being chill
yeah she's being chill oh she's like oh
squish it squish it
but yeah so
I kind of feel like the implication was
that Daniel saw it too
because he said they showed him in the
in the reenactment like come in and
being like looking like what the [ __ ]
and like they showed like the shadow man
and the real guy said I felt it before I
saw it so I'm guessing that he meant he
felt this is what its presence or
whatever this fear and sadness kind of
[ __ ] was but then he saw it too and he
said that he got the impression that
this might have been a bad Omen which
I'm imagining is what prompted them to
move like the fact that he finally saw
something or felt something and probably
she was like told you this is like
what's been going on the whole time
so but they kind of like skipped over it
a little bit on the show like they kind
of show it but it was like a couple
seconds and I was just like wait what
what just happened okay so they end up
so they moved to another house like I
said it's a sentence it's like oh by the
way they moved I was like okay so they
moved to another house and um
everything's quiet for a couple weeks
instead of the investigators who went
and did the historical research they
come back
and they say because remember how
Rebecca said about she heard the voices
like the two men's voices and something
sounded like a plane crash and said
something about the Mustang and blah
blah
so the investigators come back and they
said in 1950 there were two there was a
pilot and I guess a co-pilot or whatever
in a P-51 Mustang and they said it
crashed only 600 yards away from where
their old house is so there's that
that's not very far yeah so now to make
sure they wanted to make sure that
Rebecca wasn't faking or that she
already knew about that and was like
just giving them like the information so
they essentially test her what they do
is they bring her a list with like 20 to
25 names on it only two of these one of
them is the pile and one of them is
co-pilot and they also bring like a
whole bunch of photos to see if she can
pick the pilots like out of the photos
now they said she pretty in she
instantly like picked out their names
she's like yeah this one's this and this
one's that and they said they even told
she even told them some uh extra
information like oh yeah this guy is
Henry blah blah but he he likes being
called Hank Moore and she had like all
of this other information about them
so there's that
um she was also able to tell them when
she had all the photos she said hey one
of the guys isn't here so because she
obviously had seen him and knew what he
looked like so she knew that the photo
of him was not there and they were just
kind of like yeah she passed that test
so
um they also tell her that they found
records of an old woman named Elizabeth
Pratt Jones just like she said uh the
woman was it was from the 1700s and her
husband's business had failed and they
subsequently had all their property
repossessed weird thing about this
though is that this woman lived 30 miles
away from that house so they're not
really sure why
the woman would show up in her house 30
miles away unless she was like the only
person that could see ghosts in the area
and so she was just going around trying
to show herself to people picking it up
on a ghost internet picking it up on the
ghost internet I guess maybe that came
through the ghost or the Google search
yeah she's like who is it around here
that can see ghosts can I pop into
somebody's house and like communicate
and some [ __ ] like that but yeah so
maybe that's what it was so yeah 30
miles I don't know it was really weird
maybe 30 miles is not that much might be
the other way around maybe the ghosts
the person that can see the ghost is
subconsciously searching for a ghost in
the area and goes oh there's 130 miles
and then there it is
yeah just like it's just like an app on
your phone it's like an app
just in your subconscious
like random Nautica where if you kind of
tell it like you want to find a dead
body or a ghost or something it tells
you where the [ __ ] is yeah maybe it's
that
so now at the new house Rebecca said she
doesn't see the boy anymore they
couldn't find out anything about the boy
because she's like she saw him all the
time but she never um got an impression
of what his name was and couldn't really
figure out like what his deal was so he
couldn't really be identified
um and she didn't see the pilots again
in the new house but apparently she said
she still sees other ghosts sometimes
and has kind of learned to live with it
and accept it and everybody knows about
it now and everybody lived happily ever
after so that was pretty much the end of
that show
calling through the ghost Vine
that says Anna yeah yeah baby it's that
I mean it could be it was a good episode
it was it wasn't like it was um
a little bit unusual because it's not
like structured like like they normally
are yeah it's because the investigators
were involved that's why I did like I
did appreciate that the investigators
that were on this show like didn't seem
like I said that guy really didn't seem
to have time for like psychics and stuff
he's like I didn't bring a psychic I
brought a psychologist to make sure that
you're not crazy and that you're not
having like some mental problems I don't
blame him I wouldn't get it I don't I
wouldn't get any any psychic involved I
wouldn't either and if you do get a
psychic involved use the same one over
and over again it has a good track
record
um but I really wouldn't do that because
if you actually look at these cases the
pattern the pattern is is they get a
psychic or some kind of seer or some
kind of a local witch involved and the
case gets crazier
all right based on this chick's input
which tells me that
it's more likely she's [ __ ] spinning
the yarn and [ __ ] pulling [ __ ] out of
her ass which makes the [ __ ] story go
[ __ ] wonky and crazy
so now they have a crazy they have a
crazy story over the phenomenon and now
you can't separate the two it's better
not to say anything or involve any of
those people just let the phenomena play
out record what the phenomena is don't
try to interpret it don't try to put a
story with it you don't know any of that
just record the phenomena
look at take the phenomenon for what it
is
that's what happened to us when the
Poltergeist thing [ __ ] came about we
didn't get any psychics or anything we
just [ __ ] saw everything moving and
try to keep track of what was moving and
tried to make sense out of it we never
really could no real story behind it
it just moves things
and interacted with you
you know I mean I kind of really did
like because I was saying while you were
gone while you were downstairs I said
what about um them bringing the
psychologist along I kind of feel like
that's how Steve Mara does it yeah he
doesn't I mean he even told me a few
times it's like that he very very very
very very rarely like [ __ ] with
psychics like they don't bring them
along because it's just like money money
I mean they usually just try to
comment everything from like as
objective a point of view as possible
and like I said they do psychiatric kind
of evaluations of all the people that
are reporting the phenomena to make sure
that they're not having issues like
mental issues and they just basically
just record record
yes they do a historical background on
the house they do that but they I think
they use doesn't he usually do that
after yeah it's all after you record
first yeah all right you want to try to
get photographs
uh record what people say their
commentaries
their descriptions of what happened if
you didn't see it if you didn't catch it
on film and uh try to get Audi audio
recordings of audio phenomena and then
afterwards you try to figure out what
the [ __ ] happened
yeah don't do it you don't do it at the
time
doing that at the time especially with
psychics and [ __ ] man you'll taint the
case
yeah because that's the thing if you
know the history of the house oh like a
whole family got murdered in this house
for example like before you go to the
house to investigate that's going to
color your data because you're going to
be expecting things certain things along
that line right you know what I mean so
it probably is better and I like that
they did that in this case where it's
like she basically like I said if any of
this is true I don't really know but
it's like she basically said hey I just
hear voices in my head it's saying this
that and the other write it down and
then later they went and looked it up
and they said okay by the way this this
and this and that all line lined up with
what you said but she didn't really seem
to know anything about the [ __ ] that had
happened there beforehand so I think
that's kind of the way to go about it
but I don't know I kind of feel like a
lot of the episodes like when they do
have psychics on there like a lot of
times psychics will go out of their way
to say well when we get there we always
tell the people like not to tell us
anything like about what happened in the
house or what they've seen or blah blah
but the thing about it is that if it's a
house particularly
that is kind of well known locally for
for example like something bad happening
there then that's pretty easy to find
out yeah and I think that sometimes and
I'm not [ __ ] on all of the people or
not calling them Liars or anything like
that but I do kind of feel like some of
those kind of people will research a
place beforehand because if they know
the house that they're going to I mean
that's what I would do yeah if I was
trying to scam somebody which I wouldn't
because I don't do that kind of thing
but
um but yeah you would like look into the
history of the house and be like ooh
somebody got murdered here or some you
know what I mean it's like that one very
famous parapsychologist I think he might
have been from Germany he was the one
that did the Mr Gordy case he was old
when that [ __ ] case was happened he
said he found good success with a
particular trans medium that he used
they do an investigation and then
afterwards they bring in that trans
medium and that that guy I think was a
guy he'd go into a trance and he could
see what the problem was he could fix it
a lot of times and the phenomena would
end
but that was done after the
investigation right
yeah I kind of feel like that's sort of
the best way to go about it so that was
one thing I appreciated about this
episode is that it actually showed
a real investigation team who the guy
who was like an engineer and then like a
psychologist and they didn't have a
psychic involved or anything like that
going into it going into a trance
going astral and dealing with it
directly on the astral plane is the way
to go you just need to ask [ __ ] uh uh
what was his name Reverend Reverend moon
from the Moon he actually toppled the
Soviet Empire in astral form yeah that
was him that did that yeah that's what
that's how that happened he claimed
yeah I still want to do a show about him
I put it in the in the poll a couple
times but it didn't win but it's still
in my list out of all the Cults
Reverend Moon I think was probably the
best one uh they they did you have to
join Nicole yeah I mean please don't but
the only thing that I think was that I
didn't like about moon is that the
Moonies would use uh would separate
people from their family families if
they let if they left the church so it's
that that's he's not supposed to do
that's [ __ ] that will all cults do
that that's one of the that's one of the
defining characteristics of matter of
fact yeah but uh evidently Moon went
astral one time and he saw communism for
what it was
and then pulled a couple of strings in
the damn psychic world and caused the
Soviet Union to unravel
that's some [ __ ] I mean that's a pretty
good story like I could there now I want
to [ __ ] yeah man yeah I wish I I wish
I was like more of a huckster because
it's like I come up with all kind of
crazy [ __ ] that I did on the outside I
could write a whole book about it go in
the lecture circuit and everything I
wouldn't be able to keep a straight face
though well the thing is about that
though is
I wouldn't be able to keep my straight
face
the thing is like about that is that is
that like uh some of the people in his
church like like said no no he told us
years beforehand that he did that it was
coming down it's gonna take time but
anybody could have said that because you
could see the Soviet Union was having a
lot of troubles you know I was having a
lot of trouble but that's [ __ ] funny
though that's a good angle
well it's just kind of like when you see
you know back in the day I'm sure she's
dead now but um back in like was it in
the National Enquirer like back in the
80s and stuff they had that psychic Gene
Dixon you remember her yeah yeah she's
she's got to be dead now she's not she's
200 years old claimed that [ __ ] that
those girls were dead but it turned out
they were in [ __ ] no that was Sylvia
Brown Sylvia Brown that's right Gene
Dixon Dixon it's which one is that she
was the one that was always I mean she
was always in The Inquirer like Gene
Dixon okay yeah she was always she would
always predict I don't think she so much
got involved in like murders and stuff
but she's more seemed to predict like
celebrity stuff and like politics and
that kind of stuff and I don't know I
just kind of feel like anybody that
knows anything about cultural Trends or
anything like that it's pretty easy to
make a bunch of predictions about what's
gonna happen this year hey remember the
royal family is gonna [ __ ] up hey is
that the other thing hey there's gonna
be an earthquake in California it's like
it's always [ __ ] like that I'm like bad
hurricane in Florida we'll play toward
play to the statistics and the thing
about it is that the human brain yeah
um is kind of structured in such a way
that normally most people will only
remember what you got right and they
won't remember all the stuff that you
got wrong so by the time like if you get
if you get like one or two lucky hits
everybody will remember that holy [ __ ]
she predicted 911 or she predicted like
this big earthquake or a plane crash or
whatever everyone's gonna remember that
and they're gonna forget like the 30
other predictions she made that did not
come so just make lots of predictions
well that's what they do that's why they
Nostradamus that's why they make so many
and like I said and they always play
with the statistics they don't come with
they don't usually come up with anything
too crazy or too out there they'll
always come up with something that's
pretty likely yeah you know uh you know
at least from a statistical standpoint
so and they'll be vague enough that it
could kind of like just like
nostradamus's quad trains right he's
using archaic yeah why are they still
talking about Nostradamus today because
yeah he knew that he's using this
archaic [ __ ] French it was archaic in
the time that he's using it and it's
poems
all out of order
and you can translate it in any language
you want now
and kind of get that [ __ ] to sound like
something that happened
you can scry something out of it but
only after the fact because you're
trying to get something to happen to fit
all this [ __ ] right you go well that
fits you know so this must have been a
prediction it's never the other way
around
see that's not like well here's the
prediction and oh I know what's going to
happen it's not that that never happened
they're all post addictions yeah right
they're they're never predictions no no
because it's if it was a prediction yeah
a real prediction they'd be like okay at
7 32 p.m on this particular day in this
particular City this [ __ ] is
going to get assassinated and then it
happens that's a prediction right not
some random [ __ ] or somewhere by
a stream is gonna get shot in the face
that's not a that that's too vague right
that could be anything well even even
the so-called Nostradamus predictions
that predict Hitler and all this
they don't quite say Hitler no and they
say hister
it's the river that was a river yeah
it's a river history is what he's
talking about and then it vaguely kind
of sounds like something about that and
then in the famous man who saw tomorrow
which is a movie we grew up with we
[ __ ] love with Orson well with orison
Wells it's [ __ ] it's so fun it's so
creepy yeah he'd have you [ __ ] going
they would take [ __ ] a seven or eight
quad trains [ __ ] written down in four
or five centuries and chop them up and
put them together into one Nostradamus
prediction that was not in the not in
the book it's four of them mashed
together to try to make this sound like
he's predicting Hitler although what's
funny is that
the the movie kind of predicts a little
bit Saddam Hussein and scud missiles
and new in New York
and and and It produced it and and the
World Trade Center being attacked but
those that's different events being
mashed into one
but the quatrades don't say that just
the [ __ ] movie kind of shows that
right the quatrans don't say that just
goes to show you how you can kind of
predict anything well the thing about it
too is that since the age of the
internet people have made up quatrains
yeah and put them out there and then
they get repeated as real ones like the
more they get passed around so some of
that stuff wasn't even Nostradamus no
thanks that they're fakes and the
Germans in World War II did that the the
uh certain parts of like SS propaganda
units were
faking Nostradamus predictions yeah and
some of those I think might still be
circulating too faking them you know
that were like fake predictions that the
Germans would win certain battles you
know that yeah which is it's like
psychological warfare yeah Tammy said I
predict Tom will go off on a tangent
during one of the shows
the [ __ ] prediction is that that's a
gift that's a [ __ ] given let's see
Sammy's psychic [ __ ] Tammy's not
psychic just paying attention hahaha
American Military 100 said didn't LaToya
Jackson have a psychic hotline yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um Dionne Warwick
he's like friends right yeah yeah
because Dan Bell uses a lot of clips
from that like okay hilarious they're so
funny [ __ ] Ricky Lake and all that
[ __ ] late night coming back from work
working that was like late 80s early 90s
yeah the only thing on would be like
[ __ ] Jerry Springer had [ __ ]
infomercials trying to get you to
[ __ ] call some [ __ ] 1-800 never
yeah I remember that 900 number if it
was 1800 totally free LaToya Jackson
[ __ ]
that was just her her system
her not even her system they probably
just called up and said hey can we use
your name and image yeah yeah and like
we'll give you a million dollars or
whatever she's like sure whatever that
was before the internet
yeah Zach said I still think my favorite
fake Sidekick is Miss Cleo yeah we like
Miss Cleo with her fake Jamaican accent
yeah
I remember that [ __ ] man that one was
she was fun yeah that's that well that's
what's so funny it's like I think like
people bought into that [ __ ] these kids
today uh people bought it I promised
myself that when I got old I wasn't
gonna say these kids today so I'm saying
it ironically
but these kids today yeah you don't
before there was the internet you have
no idea sad ass people would call these
1900 numbers and it wasn't just psychics
it was psychics or
um weird sex lines like fetish lines it
was uh yeah What men's magazines was
something that does not not around
anymore it's [ __ ] porn and the back
of those things half the damn Pages were
nothing but little ads to call 1900
numbers for [ __ ] sex phone sex yeah
and it was like [ __ ] 9.99 a minute
and [ __ ]
well the psychic lines I think they were
usually like 350 for the first minute
and then 99 cents each additional minute
or something like that but their whole
thing like the um the people that they
employed where their whole thing was
like keep the people on the line as long
as possible because most of those people
were actually like working from home
actually
um and obviously like which probably
shouldn't have to be said but all those
phone sex lines those were all just like
uh models and stock photos and stuff
like the person you were calling
absolutely no of course not
and that's the thing about it too is
like the the Psychic Friends
you know you weren't calling Dion
Warwick no you were just calling some
random ass mother you were calling some
random ass woman in a trailer in Austin
Texas somewhere it was like
listening he's talking about your
problems late 90s were a trip because it
was it felt like the very very end of
the 80s it's like 80s is so [ __ ]
played out that it's [ __ ] breaking
apart and it's slowly being replaced by
aol.com and online [ __ ] which is like an
all-new world man and [ __ ]
when you were young and you're first
getting into the online scene back at
the old internet it was like you were
being you were being you were you were
first tasting freedom getting away
from the stale [ __ ] television
programs and the [ __ ] terrible Mall
culture and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] great
man
and like you were the first people to to
get off of the [ __ ] to to get off of
the [ __ ] Plantation like walking on
the moon you're free everybody else
they're still in prison you know it was
[ __ ] cool
but now they just made the internet
television now
well you knew that was you knew that was
going to come
well I mean when you get right down to
it I was thinking I was thinking about
this the other day I don't know why I
think random [ __ ] like this but
sometimes I think to myself it's like oh
you know it's kind of a shame how
everybody just kind of like you know
sits around watching you know movies on
Netflix or whatever I mean I do it too
or whatever but the thing about it is
that I'm like yeah but what the [ __ ]
else is there to do man you go back like
200 years what were those people doing
just sitting around by candlelight like
reading books to each other yeah if they
were lucky they were playing with a cat
right yeah so it's just kind of like
yeah
that's all everybody's been doing yeah
just entertaining themselves if they had
Leisure Time yep there are if you did if
you didn't have TV you read a book or
you went to a play there are paintings
of late medieval and early Renaissance
girls sitting there with paintings at
them and their cat or them and their
ferret you know what I mean and that was
some high-tech [ __ ] I got a cat
I've got a cat yeah
look what I got I got a ferret you know
it's cool we have two cats yeah
but yeah there wasn't any technology
that's what I'm saying so it's just kind
of like you know people can piss and
moan all they want about oh these kids
today just staring at their phones and
[ __ ] like that all the time I was like
well
back in the old days before they had any
technology it's like well they would
just sit there and like stare at books
or they slept when the sun went down
they'd run right have sex asleep but you
had to get used to all that damn body
hair and no bathing especially in the
winter this [ __ ] too cold well
everybody everybody was furry and stinky
back then [ __ ] so it's not like
anybody was any cleaner than anybody
else so and then they had didn't have
any diet to speak of when you look at
the clothes they were all kind of
malformed little narrow shoulders and
tell you the low protein [ __ ]
back in the day but you know that's how
it was they didn't know any better
yeah I mean and I've said this many
times I wouldn't even if somebody came
to me tomorrow and said hey I invented a
cool ass time machine do you want to go
back to the 80s I don't think I would
like there was a lot of cool [ __ ] about
the 80s I'm not saying that but I
wouldn't want to go back to a time
before internet or before any of that
stuff it's like because everything back
then even though it was cooler and maybe
you appreciated stuff more
um everything was like difficult
it's like if I wanted to see a [ __ ]
movie like I grew up and I really liked
weird ass movies and the town where I
grew up they never played weird ass
movies in the town because it was like a
redneck town so I never got to see it in
the theater I'd have to wait and wait a
wait and then like oh now it's out on
video but they didn't have it to rent in
my town either because redneck Town
you'd have to buy it so I'd have to buy
it and they're expensive yeah it's like
I'd have to save up and it's like oh
we're going to New York City this and
then I'd have to go and like buy a whole
bunch of [ __ ] while I was up there
because they didn't sell it and they
didn't have the internet so I had to
spend like a [ __ ] ton of money so and
same with like cool clothes and all that
kind of stuff they didn't sell anything
like that like around where I was so
everything now is just like so it's
gonna be easy yeah it's just so easy if
I want to watch like I can think 99.99
of the movies that I want to watch oh I
want to watch this movie like right now
I think yeah I can either watch for free
or I can watch it for like three bucks I
mean that's amazing that's amazing like
used to be you had to wait like I said
you know I gotta check the food all
right so we've been on for hour and a
half yeah okay so I guess we'll wrap it
up and we're done talking about the show
anyway
so tomorrow we're gonna do a matinee
show I don't know what movie we're gonna
do though honestly I I know that I keep
saying we really have to do Godfather
too but
um so we gotta watch something tonight
but honestly I'm just kind of I'm really
tired like I just I woke up so early
this morning for what whatever reason
so I kind of just want to watch
something kind of short and kind of fun
and blah blah because tomorrow night we
have to watch The Green Mile because
that's the movie that we're doing for
the movie retrospective and I'm pretty
sure the Green Mile is like three
[ __ ] hours long so I'm gonna have to
like gird my loins for that one so
tonight I just want to watch something
stupid and fun and everything like that
so I mean you know we did Elvis
yesterday and that was like really fun
but that was also really long although
it didn't seem long but that was like
really fun that was just a fun movie so
I don't know I just maybe I'll just
watch like a fun slasher or a fun horror
movie or something like that but we'll
find out tomorrow you'll find out same
time we find out maybe uh so thank you
everybody for dropping by today and
hanging out with us on a haunting show
hopefully you enjoyed it and we will see
you again talking about uh a movie
tomorrow evening good night